okay goodbye chats for the next three
minutes I'm gonna try and avoid looking
at the chats and we'll start the rush
okay there we go
pause for a moment there okay
starts off easy free night three nights
free mates free mates and your face
mates
that's a pin and win this is promotion
eventually this is a nice mate queen
take c2 this is ninety five most likely
can always play king b1 and then take a
free night this is me this is Q er this
is opposition or this is wait wait wait
wait
there there there probably this move no
should have took my time okay this is
classic tactic so I missed one but I'm
still on a roll 15 down let's take a
night let's Sacko Queen botas gambit
style take this and back rank means we
have fork we have sucker rock and mates
oh this should be simple it assists this
and this what's going on here so many
things going on
takes a pawn rook t5 chops of Queen very
nice
this is free rook right free rook Bishop
here looks decent let's take let's take
here god be good take on g2 we take on
oh wait the bishops hanging I have to
take here okay made in one let's take
and win a queen but what do I do here
take some takes c3 is coming okay that's
okay
takes fork
all about getting to 35 I can take the
thing and then take on okay takes and
takes nine takes each - what is this
probably some Intermezzo like Bishop
takes off seven or queen h5 except seven
when they try g6
not sure about this I'm a d4 and some
line d4 then no amen
a queen seat and then rook a one no okay
that was a fail
I got thirty I should probably analyze
what I miss what was this one I've seen
this one before
what was it oh we just take a free
bishop free bishop yeah point of queen
c3 is it's very multi-purpose defending
threatening to trap the the queen
threatening c6 and threatening this so I
had three threats block defended two of
them but not this one okay
this one oh this one I played King f5
that was wrong why is this wrong okay so
here King f5
oh maybe light breaks through somehow so
it's just king before king c3 huh why is
this not working
Oh King out five King g3 ah there's no
breakthrough okay uh I forgot to plug in
the laptop again
okay laptop revived nice was the last
one oh this one this one was weird
was this fun there are a lot of ideas so
the point is after King takes yeah so I
was calculating King takes h2 Queen h4
King g1 Queen takes g3 and then d4 I
guess that doesn't work cuz bishop takes
d4 I wanted like Queen takes d4 but
after pawn takes d4 just doesn't work
oh so queen h5 is a move oh we need five
attacks tonight with a queen okay
I was simpler than I expected okay
lessons learned hello to more people
thanks Duffman omega Nick
omegis Nick I don't know why I said SH
Nick thanks for your comments welcome to
twitch from Germany it's got to be lathe
in Germany right approaching midnight
what do you do when you get bored of
chess when I get bored of chess I stream
puzzle rush okay young rolf something
something woot
okay okay um let's play some more puzzle
rush let's try and break 30 how do I
start a new thing whoa heart wise in
middle 1000 bits thanks so much I'm
struggling with starting a new thing
let's just go to the puzzle rush okay
thanks so much heart wise a noodle
welcome back
if you're just joining I'm trying to
break 35 and puzzle rush to qualify for
this thing and and to qualify I have to
stream myself getting to 35 and then
share it on Twitter or if a
book so let's try to answer your
question about becoming a GM nightbot
can provide an answer soaking wet sigh
welcome back Brian
$29.99 piano welcome to the live stream
okay let's do this
take a knight or take a bishop yes back
rank mates back rank mates
take up on back rank mates
what does this take a free rook what
color am I I'm black pawns are going
that way that's fork let's take this
thing take the rook let's do probably
this move and then no huh that's
probably something simple okay let's
take those free piece c3 should trap the
Queen this is a fork this is a smothered
mate almost this is free bishop this is
free material can probably take this
thing lots of ideas here probably rip d2
let's take this Queen e5 and win the
rook Queen I five should win the bishop
this looks like maybe mating maybe
winning a queen come in the night okay
it's pork let's take this and then win
the Queen now the four is reasonable and
then take a Bishop King G to mean most
logical move and then rook h1 take this
probably take inmates c5 and these are
tricky puzzle rush got harder um can
check I'll be check no d4 has to work
okay let's take this is made into and
probably do this classic idea this
should be made in three one two and
three this is I mean something with 93
take this in Knight g3 what's going on
here
Queen d6 I'm blinking I'm not seeing it
Queen d6 they were there there I mean
okay maybe Bach was threatening
something I should probably take this
and take on b7 this has got to work
this is meeting eventually I'm so close
I can't get mated stake of pawn and what
is this Knight h6 he's looking at 96
pawn takes Queen g4 I just missed it
mmm that's so frustrating what was this
one it's not a chick sirs King f8 ah
so maybe Knight f6 same idea but
stronger hmm okay let's learn some
lessons starting with this one
Ralph Wiggum thanks for the 34 bits
matching my score my disappointing score
my sensitive my sensitivity looks too
high yeah my mouse is maybe slightly
oversensitive but it works for me
35 for a sub okay I'll get there
eventually
oh so this one I played queen c1
calculating key needs to Queen f4 g3
Queen digs f3 but the Queen on b7
defends f3
so as a Queen e1 Oh Queen e1 Queen e1
right we need one Bishop f4 oh wait the
Queen took on b5 Oh
but okay the line I initially calculated
there's Kim Ji Won okay yeah this is
just crushing okay so that was one this
one I thought was winning but maybe
there's something more winning I played
rook b8 rook be a king a5 Dragon Kings C
5 D 6 etc so maybe at c5 here c5 is a
only other move let's calculate c5 king
takes e5 oh just check okay I was
looking to win the rook not the White
Queen okay and one more you blame toilet
noggin yeah toilet noggin to take the
blame you can use a toilet noggin emotes
this one I think is just 9 of 6 yeah
okay alright well I improved from the
first one let's try this again
deep breath let's do this
okay back rank mates it is hard to talk
and play sometimes I do try and provide
some commentary at least for the easier
ones Bishop h6 wins I mean the King's
outside the box let's do this and
probably take with pawn this is looking
93 what else oh I take on e4 okay what
to do here neither four is interesting
g5 is a move hey it's a sub Caesar Cobb
thanks for subbing okay let's try and
stay focused
check check and Queen g3 mates mmm
probably just take here like this and
take taking one a queen another sub funk
thank you for subbing did my best not to
mispronounce that let's take this thing
and take a Bishan probably take a bishop
take this and Bishop e7 o takes takes b5
as a move it's gotta be b5 no that was
just a guess oh I can't even do that I
can do this so okay looking good
take the fish up and take the knight
almost getting mated here but not quite
hmm my e8 some move okay
take six takes and then takes
what to do here I want to win the Queen
in the end so Bishop here and that miss
and then when the Queen what is this
which way are the pawns going to take
probably this no huh
gotta be this move right no it's this
move I don't know if I'm gonna make it
this one 28mm let's play this move Nate
take a rook
five more let's go mm I'm not sure
probably King here say this I don't know
her time's running out
ahhh Wow
two more let's go Oh
Oh as the Queen takes f7 had a nice run
there one of those I was just guessing
every move towards that yeah the second
to last one I was just guessing thirty
three and three minutes tough
I feel slow with the mouse - it is like
it's weird sensitivity so it feels under
sensitive and then when I move it fast
it's like oversensitive thanks again
Ralph Wiggum maybe I can just keep like
scoring just under 35 and keep receiving
Ralph Wiggum bits and then eventually
buy a house probably not the most
efficient way to make a living though
[Music]
dog i25 thanks for subbing and thanks to
other subs - okay I'm trying to get to
35 I've been close I think I scored 30
the first time 34 and now 33 oh yeah
what was a this one I just played b5
without really doing any sort of work
probably nights 97 oh this is nice mate
nights are gonna land on B and C a tie
think I just want to get the
satisfaction a four oh wait a minute
Obi five wow there's another line I
thought where a king be six well maybe
it doesn't work
nevermind okay what was other one oh
this one I really didn't think there was
a difference I have to take the pawn and
then and then get the opposition okay
and then this one oh yeah this one at
the end I just had to take on a seven I
think
and then g6
yeah threatening g7 and Queen h7 okay
oh disable mouse acceleration how do I
do that Logitech Logitech Gaming
software okay I've never actually used
this mouse tell me what to do tell me
what to do I don't know what to do
dpi is like there's so many buns look at
this Mouse
it's just it's too complicated
[Music]
wasn't worth paying the extra money for
more buns it's just more confusing I am
on a Mac too so I don't know if this is
so great to use this mouse on a Mac it
was I think it was around like $50 Oh
Mac our IP okay that's great to hear
oh maybe in one level oh it feels it
feels different now it feels a little
bit different so now there's just one
level okay let's try and get used to
this
okay I think the mouse is a big factor
in puzzle rush deep breath it's not get
distracted yeah now I'm trying to adjust
to this like new Mouse feeling
breakthrough I was moving too quickly
okay stay calm deep breath well does
this one Queen rook team one oh no [ __ ]
it takes you six kh4 wins a queen takes
rook th win the night
this is trapping the Queen or no yes it
is
what is this I'm white push up on take
upon take oh no I was expecting Queen
Daisy to knock Queenie three it's so
tricky
okay traffic Queen is still in
contention I just can't miss another
problem say this move when a queen yeah
I've been moving too quickly check when
when a bishop probably this move and
promote should activate the king oh this
is nice it's got to be this taking Queen
D for probably hmm it's got to be
trapping the Queen somehow Ricky -
probably or brookie - okay
take some Queen 84 probably take here
and take care I'll be off a piece
no I guessed again I shouldn't guess so
bad all I had me than two as well I
denied of six and I have six my e6 it's
just made into his first one I just
played the most natural-looking room
which is terrible with his Bishop d7 ID
rook rook d4
thanks again Ralph Wiggum I tried my
best
okay sir Luke t4 was other one oh yeah
this one I had so I can explain what I
did wrong I was just expecting Queen
takes e to so I just played rook T to
not realizing White has another move
Queen III and here probably Bishop F one
looks correct and blacks up black has
like rooking two bishops for a queen
okay
search up Mouse settings
whoa chess weed with our raid 78 people
things chess we've um yeah I could go to
my I'm on a Mac by the way so Mac's are
sometimes tricky um okay here's my mouse
enemies not sure if this is gonna help
me at all huh yeah this is not gonna
help
I was probably better off with other
other setting menu I'll just try and get
used to it
let's go again I think mine like my
chest needs more improvement than my
mouse settings yeah shout out to chef
speed if you're just joining I'm trying
to break
35 in puzzle rush and I'm getting close
but I'm still
failing let's close all these tabs Swami
failed puzzles okay oh I didn't want
that tab okay there we go
let's go again this time I'll make it
yeah just for you
wait what happened yeah let's go puzzle
rush and start three two one
back right mates yes back ring mates
tray Queens back ring mates
Wow four out of five docking mates take
a free night another free nights another
free nights free Bishop free night free
Bishop free mate promotion tactic but
where ooh
here this no oh I had to take the Queen
first okay let's work a bishop take a
knight
I'm really just trying to get 35 does
this takes takes oh i trap a queen when
a knight this is should be meeting
eventually what is this what does this
takes I could just win the rook okay hmm
both works hanging
porca Bishop rook 8 looks interesting
takes takes should be working
hmm I could take here there we go
push uh what to do what to do
oh this move and then chop the Queen
somehow okay that's good enough gotta be
this okay check check um admit I didn't
see that but where's the win should have
to not seeing it
Oh take a free bishop probably this move
hmm Queen a6 is a move no do this move
I'm still close still very close no 32
oh that's so unfortunate I tried so hard
okay let's learn some lessons oh this
one yeah I just I don't know what
happened yeah so if I promote first I
just thought promote first rook takes
Queen then Queen takes Queen but white
can throw in Queen da check there's this
one yeah what was this one oh I can take
the rook on f8 yeah okay yeah Queen a6
was that's not good and then this one I
was running out of time chess BAE
what's up Jess pay this one I played
Brooke c1 which looked most natural
Ralph Wiggum
thanks for the bits rook takes over
takes be 7 because f7 is a target
valiant efforts I appreciate those words
but I have to be even more valiant yeah
so I should I should avoid mistakes very
wise advice and I should move quickly to
those are the keys to success let's go
again
okay rook h1 guaranteed bishop yeah it
starts off easy you just have to get
through these quickly and not mouse slip
it's when a queen h3 7 um yeah this is
good take on probably take here in g1
mate take here and then take here when
the night Queen c8 okay I'm on pace
let's take and push it strap a rook this
is made into chopping a rook again takes
takes this is working because I take
with check you can take the rook right
takes takes oh I can take the Queen
I should be six okay like this and take
the knight and then take the rook no
what does this have to take the roof
uh takes and then takes okay
Oh what is this takes no take on G to
probably take here or no take here
no the tilt tilt is real oh this is just
a draw okay um let's do yeah I'm stuck I
don't know why I'm so stuck let's move
I'll take the bishop still have hope a
little bit of hope
easy peasy bye miss - that's not
acceptable C Phi oh no Bishop a5 and
then c5 on passant nice okay let's go
three nights oh no I have to check take
and then three nights g5 let's get some
g5 emotes job g4 two more let's go there
they're going takes f1 one more it's
gotta be this right it's gotta be yes
not sure why it was that probably steel
matrix I get 240 might be difficult
what is this 24
what is this no lost control of the
mouse this final one the final ones
actually interesting oMG he got $10,000
wait what you tried maybe you were
trying to distract me
oh no the the $10,000 prize is for the
winner of the championship this is just
a qualify but yeah no I'm on I'm on
track to get 10,000 $10,000 I just need
to beat out everyone who's competing in
the championship thanks everyone for the
38 bits
Ralph Wiggum Tunes our thanks for the
sub and who else was that soaking wet
psy
5 times 38 what's 5 times 38 107 no 190
some number and mag firmer and firmer
thanks for the sub and Danny Matt thanks
for the slug wow so many people subbing
I should break 35 more often and Joe Joe
the person are you actually a person
thanks for subbing ok so if I'm not
mistaken
maybe chest bait can confirm this
there's arena kings starting in one hour
and two minutes hopefully someone can
confirm that and I plan on playing ok
chess play says yes so I'll be back in
about an hour for arena Kings its
knockout well I pour tea I didn't drink
a single sip of tea the stream it's been
brewing it's been brewing for too long
that's so strong